[Music]
expensive fancy show I'm not complaining
about life over Bravo Bravo in front of
a dead moon it's 1 1 60 watt bulb is out
and no one can join out of this the dead
moon is good God quickly this show this
episode won't air your tests webisodes
yes exactly good my woman will ever see
this these people are all paid actors oh
you know I want to ask you speaking of
getting in trouble you co-hosted CNN's
New Year's Eve yeah with Anderson Cooper
you two have a great chemistry I enjoy
watching you but you got into some
trouble is that right is that fair to
say you got a little trouble because I
tried to blow him look let me tell you
something
I'm a newswoman I'm practically an
anchor over there at CNN at this point
every year Anderson Cooper is like
please do something really offensive
please and I'm like okay whatever
Anderson so this year there was actually
a remote and you know during New Year's
to go to this theater that city we were
going to Eastport Maine kind of year old
hood
yeah similar area a couple of thousand
miles away but yeah similar short drive
and they actually have a thing where a
yearly tradition where they kiss the
sardine kiss the sardine yeah so what
happened was well do you have a clip we
have a clip of what happened yeah that's
because I'm not ashamed to say I tried
to kiss the sardine okay
that's your issue that's where you're
coming with you is you I feel like it's
your issue no it's not my issue Maya I
stand by my issue at all I say go for it
man I'm happy with all that stuff no it
was it was I thought that you had to
write some apologies after this every
year they fire me
oh yeah it's my seventh year in a row
every every January first I get fired
and they want me to apologize and then I
don't and then a rat like at the
eleventh hour they rehire me but they
did actually get the highest ratings
since 2008 and I think it's because I
kissed Anderson sardine all right let's
take a look at this moment and decide
for ourselves tell us that no one has
ever gotten sick from kissing the
sardine and 2013 here in Planet
[Applause]
Anderson Cooper clearly couldn't handle
that that was it's just giving up he ie
is just beaten down like a pound dog at
this point he is just sitting there like
we used to try to rehearse and then he
would call me the day before and say
like I just got back from Jalalabad what
do you want to do and now honestly he's
like I don't want even talk to you I'll
just see you there he knows I'm gonna
always try to pull something and then it
looks like you were going back down
there I tried all night I tried all
night to kiss him that's thanks for that
ash in the Charlie Brown peering across
the river
two of the creepiest images I need to
see anything I'm not afraid of the
creepy okay so CN n you think they're
having you back oh they'll be begging I
don't know I have no idea